>>> RUMP I
MAKING NEWLANOFI
HOUSE WITH HIMO IDA
STORY FORSOR
O WHY DOES TRUMP THINK
THAT T DOCUME E
CLASSIFI A TNDREDS OF TH PRESID
TH'RE HIROOs IN ANRGUMENT THATTH
REG CUMENTS, PTORS
PRIDESIDENGE ZITT AL RECOR AT ET
L RECORDS AND OK THE M
THAT SHOULD BE ALLOWED.
S SAYING
CAE  IS NOT HOW IT WORKSE YOURM
THOS
TRRGRS BUT TULD BE COVERED BY E
HAPPEN.THIS IS GAMESMANSHIP.  TI
AND THE OUT COME OF A SEPARATE
INVESTIGATION INUD DEALINGS IN .
WHS GOING ON. R HIS HOME WAS
ICS ED.
FEDERAL INVESTIGS,
INFORMED A JUDGE THAT EIR
PHONE LOBBYINGLOSE
THLIAN
WONDERFUL NEWS, OFOUAT IART PRO.
IS A CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION  EF
MEDDLING IE 20LECTION
D GIUL HAS BEE HE IS
TA IN THAT INVESTIGATION.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SARAG FOR US.
LET'S GET MOG
JOINI US AN
S JOINING US AS
WELL, IN THE MARAGINVESTIGAT W
OF THERU LT YOEARD ABOUT.
THT RSEGAL
THAT HE COULJU DEFINE WHAT A
PERSONAL RECORD IT IS JUSTIOUS.
S CONTRARYTHE INES PRESIDENTIAR
IDT COUR OF HIS DUTIES AND IF TT
RU PRESIDENTIA
THEM, I AM MAKING TM
PERSONALDS.PERSONAL S TH WE Y S.
E IC COULDN'- HE LOSA CASE IN
NE WHERE SUBPOENA OF
DIFFERENCE.ST  ANY
D THAT ACOD  AND AT THE SA NONSI
ASSIST AND ADVISTRUMP'S LAWYERI
THE PRENZEG IGNITION
THAT IDE
WHAT IS YO REACTION TO THAT.
RESPONSIBLE FOR THESN
THFI OF THE E
CO
AD.S JUSE
I MEANAGAID AGAIN WE HEAR THEME
ESBOVEHETH A PRESIDAND THERE ARN
MARGU TE E.
SIFY DTSUS
IT DOESN'T PROCESS.
THE IN A R
OF LAW SYSTEM.
SO, I THINK THAT THE COURT
GOING TO GIVE SHORT  TO
THES GEORGE, TODAY IS THE
DAY THAT THE JANUARY 6 SELECT
COMMITTEE HAD HOPED HE FORR PRE.
ESWARD ANDISHFUL THINKING,
THE E  DTOW THATTRUMP IS UNWILLX
NEVER WAS GOG TOAT.EXGREAT.
FLED THE FIFTH AMENDMENT 44S IA
IE SHOUAV IF HEERW UP TO TESTI
SUBJTHAT
EMAS
LAWYERS JUSTECIDED T
RUN OUE OCK.S MET IT
OT LIKSOLVEDHE ENDTHIS CONGRESS
AN TIME THITTE
IT
DISSOLVE.
>> WE SHALL SEE . S UP THIS
ES TRUMP TO RUN T NK I
WILL BE ENOUGH TRUMP DEL
TACTIC.
I LARGELY AGRE GS ASSESSMENT OF
NONFRIVOLOUS -- IN THE RAFT
ARGUS AS THROW
, AG I
F IT DOES HAVE MORE
TO E
ARGENIT WASUS BSUPREM
CASE THAT HE WHEN S
IMPEACHMEN AND TQU IS HOW FAR US
MEA UNTIL THE  THEY WILLFOR THES
>> AND WE'RE TGE